I lost hundreds of thousands of dollars
on hype house was the rent the place was
$50,000 a month and I put a $90,000
security deposit that's gone that was
the former phas house right yeah yeah
and it's funny cuz so many people
thought they were like dude this guy's
making Bank off of all these people in
hype house actually I don't sign anyone
why not cuz they were equally a part of
it as much as I was everyone was putting
equal effort into this thing it wasn't
like I'm making hype house to make money
and so I was just like I'm not taking a
percentage of anyone it just felt wrong
there has to be positive though no no no
hype house is a net negative really
absolutely I have been through five
legal disputes in 3 years where I did
nothing wrong I'm proud that I have
helped a lot of people in my eyes not
every business you create right it's
going to be profitable what a lesson to
get out of the way early though five
lawsuits yeah is insane yeah no lawsuits
are not fun I wish that I could share
details on them but you can't